Aufklärung, Kuliskopie. Sie beginnen mit der allgemeinen Einführung. Dann, wir möchten
bei Ihnen eine sogenannte Darmspiegelung durchführen. Das ist ein Eingriff zur Untersuchung des Inneren
Ihres Dickdarms oder mit diesem Eingriff können wir das Innere Ihres Dickdarms Untersuchung oder
ansehen und außerdem können wir dabei eine Gewebeprobe zur Untersuchung im Labor entnehmen,
gegebenenfalls dann Modul-Biopsy. Bei dieser Untersuchung können wir auch gleich behandeln,
wenn wir zum Beispiel eine Blutung oder ein Polypen finden, können wir dies gegebenenfalls auch gleich
behandeln. Dies ist ein risikoharmer Routine-Eingriff. Ich werde Ihnen später noch genauer die
möglichen Risiken und Komplikationen erklären. Dann erfolgt die Aufklärung über das Modul-Endoskop,
dann bei der Vorbereitung die Teile Nüchternheit bzw. Abführen und Daumenreinigung. Dann vor
dem Eingriff bekommen Sie ein Beruhigungsmittel, damit merken Sie von dem Eingriff kaum etwas.
Zum Ablauf des Eingriffs spezifisch, wir leiten Gas in den Darmen ein,
dadurch wird der Darm aufgebläht, so können wir das Innere des Darms vollständig sehen.
Der Eingriff ist normalerweise nicht besonders schmerzhaft, kann aber unangenehm sein. Wenn Sie es
möchten, können wir Ihnen vor dem Eingriff ein leichtes Beruhigungsmittel geben.